lala personne et le pluralisme
jujuridique de l'Université McGl
SaSans donner un cours de droit
ininternational, faites la
didifférence en deux mots entre
leles deux instances? Une pour
leles disputes entre les pays?
- - C'est ça, la compétence pour
leles litiges entre états.
PoPoursuivre des individus aux
crcriminels dans une perspective
pupunitive.
- - On a vu que l'Ukraine a dépé
dedevant la cour internationalee
jujustice une requête pour que a
rereste l'intervention de la
RuRussie, est-ce que c'est un ds
éléléments CLAC pourrait régler?
- - Ça va prendre quelques temp,
mamais la cour peut ordonner des
memesures provisoires, ordonnéeà
lala Russie d'arrêter tout actee
viviolence sur le territoire de
l'l'Ukraine. Ça pèse dans la
gegestion.
- - Je me demande quel pouvoir
réréel la cour internationale de
jujustice peut avoir pour ordonr
ququoi que ce soit à la Russie,
alalors que la Russie c'est même
papas présenté à la cour
ininternationale de justice lun?
- - C'est un choix stratégique.
PaParfois, il se présente pas.Ça
sese retourne contre eux. La
RuRussie, elle reconnaît
plpleinement la compétence de la
cocour internationale de justic.
C'C'est l'organe des Nations
enen justice. Malgré tout,
efeffectivement, la Russie a
dédécidé de ne pas se faire
rereprésenter en disant que les
rerevendications de l'Ukraine, a
vavalait pas la peine. Peut-être
quque les journalistes de Moscou
onont trouvé un avion... mais is
sosont pas du tout d'accord avec
UkUkraine, comme vous pouvez
l'l'imaginer.
- - Parlons maintenant de la cor
pépénale internationale, car on
sasait qu'il y a un procureur qi
a a demandé de se pencher sur ls
crcrimes contre l'humanité, les
crcrimes de guerre, ça répond
exexactement à ces définitions,
nonon?
- - La Russie est dans une
sisituation précaire car sur tot
lele territoire de l'Ukraine,
c'c'est une compétence qui
s's'exerce en continu, en temps
réréel avec le procureur qui est
avaverti et qui observe les
viviolations du droit des confls
ararmés au fur et à mesure
ququ'elles se commettent. C'est
unune situation plutôt favorablà
l'l'Ukraine. Bien sûr, il faut
fafaire attention à ce qu'on vot
àà la télévision et la preuve
guguerre. Ça va prendre un peu
plplus de travail de temps, mais
onon a énormément d'information.
- - Il faudra accuser une persoe
ouou on peut accuser le commandt
dedes armées? Celui qui tire le
mimissile en question?
- - Plus c'est difficile à prour
ququand on avance dans la chaîn.
OnOn peut moins s'en prendre à s
sosoldats, à des généraux...
mamalgré tout, on a réussi à
obobtenir des condamnations pour
dedes crimes contre l'humanité r
onon sait très bien que les
popolitiques, les militaires sot
exexécutants de politique qui st
apappelés à être exécutés un pls
hahaut niveau qu'eux.
- - D'abord, il faut recueillira
prpreuve, et il faudra mettre ça
enen oeuvre?
- - N'oublions pas que la
cocompétence de la cour pénale
ininternationale, elle date de
202014, l'invasion de la Crimée.
LeLe procureur travaille sur ce
dodossier déjà d